within hours of events in Brussels
security at train stations and airports
in the UK was increased more armed
police were deployed trains from some
pancras Eurostar terminal to the
continent was suspended security was
visibly strengthened we are stepping up
a presence at transport hubs and at
major airports but that is purely for
the purpose of reassurance and doesn't
reflect any intelligence that we have
about a threat to London the UK threat
level remains the same severe one down
from the highest level it means that an
attack is highly likely but not imminent
the threat is so difficult to deal with
it's simply not possible to reduce it to
zero and that I'm afraid is the grim
reality of what we face today the images
of the brussels metro will remind people
of what happened in london on 77 it is
exactly what the UK security services
have been training for a major exercise
was held last month to rehearse for
multiple attacks in the capital i will
be fairly confident that in terms of
resources if a similar prophecy happened
in London our response will be probably
as good as it can be but even then
lessons would still be learned and we
will learn lessons from what's happened
in Brussels airports are near the top of
the terrorist hit list they are high
profile security is tight airside but
arrivals and departure halls are semi
public areas and so they are soft
targets as proven in Brussels train
stations even
behavior detection offices operators
Heathrow Gatwick and busy rail terminals
in the UK they're looking for the
anomalies they're looking for the people
that are potential bombers or gunmen now
we can train people with those skills
and I think in the short term that's
what we need to do outside Downing
Street this afternoon the Foreign
Secretary was deep in a long
conversation with one of the generals in
charge of coordinating the military
response if there was a terrorist attack
in the UK senior figures in British
security admit that the probably will be
a successful terrorist attack in London
or the UK sometime soon but when you
consider the wider threat to Europe and
to the country they have been remarkably
successful in foiling any attack so far
and that has been down to good
intelligence gathering because by the
time a terrorist reaches an airport or
train station it is really too late
Alistair bundle Sky News London